Matt Walsh saying that we would all be
worse off if slavery never exists
trigger warnings the dumbest argument
you ever heard yes if we're reimagining
the world without African slavery then
we have to also imagine it without all
other forms of global slavery since
African slavery was merely one variety
one offshoot actually what we can say is
that we'd all end up worse if uh slavery
never existed at all across the entire
Globe because a change that's
significant would likely shift the
course of events in a way that would
mean none of us would even exist it
would be a world full okay dub easy dub
Checkmate have you considered the
Multiverse Ethan the admiration from the
picture bring back slavery hurry there's
no reason to ever talk about like
alternative history so if that's how you
end every argument what was the
Holocaust didn't happen you wouldn't
exist like it's like oh okay uh bring
back the Holocaust I'm a racing from the
city yeah this is the most childish
argument I've ever heard and you know
some dumbasses are going that boy he's
so right he's got a lot